I need go back here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you I'm very well I had a
very short stint in wrestling I was the
Iron Sheik the Iron Sheik was one and
done as a what happened I in trust
they didn't trust the testing the
testing didn't go well how you doing
everything good life's good for you yeah
okay everything's great you did a
fantastic job on the trap thank you sir
very single year I know that's the
equivalent of a broadcaster giving birth
254 times I gave birth 254 times the
contraction started at 10 minutes and
then down to 7 and then down to 5 for
the rest that's basically what you know
[Music]
so in all serious comic alling Nets
games and that season's over obviously
and then NC double-a tournament games
you're just you're making some some
playoff basketball rounds right now
correct is that big yeah ok yeah I
worked the the Nets Philadelphia series
in the first round in New York for yes
yeah series and went five games Mets
gave him a little scare in the first
game Philly got its act together great
game for that could have really turned
the series into something else but 76ers
held on there and then blew out the nets
and Game five all in all really
successful season for Brooklyn
definite moves in the right direction
and now an interesting offseason and
with TNT I got assigned this
Philadelphia Toronto series the first
two games games three and four are on
ESPN ABC and then Greg Anthony Roz gold
on would a and I are back for Game five
in Toronto next Tuesday
which reeks of being pivotal the game
fives are either decisive there either
decisive or pivotal yeah I taught in
broadcasting school that if you're gonna
say Game five you've got to have either
decisive or pivotal there's no others
before there's no other there's no other
it's either decisive or pivotal there's
that's the math that's the only math if
you get to a game five and on you don't
graduate without that vernacular no you
must lose it you must and in the same in
the same way anything that happens in
the UK it's across the pond anything
that happens in Australia is down under
otherwise we're fired it is in our
contract or is that 100 percent so
that's why I say it reeks of pivotal
because the the way the first two games
mapped out what were the Sixers able to
do do you think in game two that that
might be repeatable tonight and and
moving forward yeah much better job
defensively on Kawhi Leonard I thought
Ben Simmons took on the challenge their
double teams were smarter better
rotations defensively against Kawhi and
then problems for Toronto generating
offense if it wasn't Kawhi Leonard in in
Game two they got a little bit more out
of Kyle Lowry there was a come to earth
moment for Pascal siakam who was
fantastic in Game one
Gasol did not give them much offensively
their bench has been a no-show so far
Danny Green didn't shoot it well so
Toronto still put themselves in a
position to possibly force overtime and
and maybe come back and turn it around
in that game too but get Philly a lot of
credit I thought Bret Braun handled
things really well from Game Wanda Game
two didn't push the panic button and
there's usually this this reaction is
overreaction after game one zip series
because you form a very strong opinion
and the reality is that Philadelphia has
a lot of talent a lot of pride and
they're still developing chemistry this
group just didn't play all that much
together they basically played a grand
total of 10 games together before the
the postseason started so this is still
a
work in progress for a team that made
bold moves and a GM Elton Brand that
swung for the fences yeah I know Tobias
Harris being such a crucial addition and
obviously with injuries is that is that
really the number right around just ten
games as this unit is played together
that's amazing
that is you know look the process was
such a big part of conversation the way
that Philadelphia did it and I think
they realized at some point that they
needed to make some bolder moves if they
wanted to truly compete at a pace that
the fanbase expected they've waited long
enough you just look at the numbers it's
it's scary to think this team was was a
ten win team and the fanbase stayed
patient and understood for the most part
that this was going to take a lot of
time before they could really get it
going there were 47 and 199 before they
busted out and won 28 games in 2016
right it was the first time that that
you thought to yourself alright maybe
there's something here and B got healthy
Ben Simmons obviously got healthy and
then last year they were 50-plus win
team they went 50-plus again this year
and they're they're going for it in
their eyes the East is wide open and
they should feel that way rich an eagle
here on the Rich Eisen show of course it
all just comes down to when you put it
in a blunder can can you beat the the
Warriors when it all is said and done in
Golden State now ten wins away ten w's
away from going back to back to back
which team that's you've seen in front
of you
has the best chance do you think to
knock them off and that you think the
Rockets coming back from a no to hole
which is obviously a big task I was
really confident in Milwaukee the team
that I saw down the stretch of the
regular season that I saw on the first
round of the playoffs obviously Game one
of this Boston series was a bit
concerning they had some bumps in the
road in Game two and then third quarter
they flipped the switch and we'll see
we've seen their rough patch and whether
or not they got that out of the way they
have to go to Boston to games now
they're against a really confident group
even though they're not a hundred
percent and no Marcus smart still
they've played with a fire and it
finally feels as if all of the the big
plans that were put forth for the
Celtics they've they've seen the vision
of Brad Stevens and and it's beginning
to form again you know this Toronto team
is is very good but any team I bring up
is just going to pale in comparison to
what Golden State brings and the
firepower combined with the experience
combined with the coaching it's really
hard to make a case for anybody else and
this hasn't been the smoothest road but
with that said when they get to this
stage it's it's hard to debate they are
truly the best team in the NBA and it
may require Kevin Durant going elsewhere
until we can start having a much deeper
conversation about what team could one
day replace us I'm not convinced he's
going anywhere I'm really I'm really
yeah I'm not I know that what the
reporting isn't the latest thing is and
I know in our last conversation you were
saying that the Nets are preparing
themselves to be a in actual viable
destination come July 1st and the
reporting over the last several days is
the Nets will be considered by the top
athletes that are available top free
agents that are available as if that is
news you know I'm not convinced he that
that that he is he's no longer the guy
who joined the team that he couldn't
beat he's no longer that guy he's the
back-to-back NBA Finals MVP he's got the
best chance to do it back to back to
back why in the world would he break
that up going into a new arena I'm sure
they could come up with some sort of
finances that makes him feel special and
wide leave that why in the world leave
any of that is what I think it's going
to come down to yeah agree with
everything that you just said it makes
although the sense
all the logic that you laid out but I
think Kevin does be to his own drum and
it is a bit of a complicated guy not in
a negative way but I think he has some
alternate views on this now that doesn't
mean that it's automatic and he pops up
somewhere else because he wants to
create a new image and a new era in some
other city I do think there will be some
serious discussions we we haven't even
seen Golden State make their cases right
they still have business to take care
well that's that's part of making their
case that's part of making their case
well and as long as they can actually
come to work and live with one another
over the stretch of another eight months
log you know to me I don't know it just
seems to me why would you that this this
goose is laying Platinum eggs you know
and and I don't know I don't know why
they write do anything other than just
do their best to keep them together and
they've got the the coaching staff and
they've got the front office and
ownership that can make their case with
another trophy and I think they will I
think they will I think that the part
that we don't know and even reporters
who have gone out on a Ledge and it made
very large statements about what's going
to happen they don't know is the
day-to-day interpersonal relationships
and dynamic behind-the-scenes of how
these guys interact and what the feeling
is between the core group if they have
another run in them and I'm not talking
about another year I'm talking about
another three four years together to go
out and try to make legitimate history
and until this season is over and this
championship run comes to an end mm-hmm
I'm not even sure that they've dealt
with it the idea that Kevin Durant knows
exactly that's gonna do right now is is
laughable I don't think he does I think
he's also in a period of trying to
figure out what his future is and what
makes the most sense for the next phase
of his career well if the Knicks do get
the first overall pick
if the the Dolan Carmo somehow does not
drag them asunder the night that the
ping pong balls are put in the terrine
or whatever they put them in if Zion
winds up in the hands of the next then
we might revisit this conversation yeah
maybe I do that you know
all right on so you're are you are you
just off this weekend are you just like
hanging with family this weekend is that
what you do yeah I don't like to
publicly admit that but yes my mom
nothing so what do you do I mean do you
golf do you play God I'm in what do you
do I do not you do not golf okay so what
do you do
I mean do you I how about probably well
I probably binge Brock Meyer I'll
probably can I want to happen
I like that yeah are you gay mr. rattle
are your Thrones guy are you game of
Thrones guy that's a tough subject I am
NOT oh I'm not AGoT guy see not and you
know I love television yes I know of the
history I I just never got into it and I
don't see myself doing it tonight come
time soon I'll give you a binge Barry on
HBO have you seen that oh yeah I'm up to
date okay okay okay all right very good
and I appreciate have you watched I'm
sorry yet
I'm stories of course I have I've been
on an episode of that I know you have
you were great handing out goldfish at a
kids party
much to the dismay of all the cast
members yes yeah which I would never do
that's a fun show I would never dairy
get you all right well again I
appreciate now that we are on be our
live on the rich Ozzy - I appreciate the
Brio with which you read The Prodigy
yeah lot of synergy also you know what a
rich yes lanky lefty that's another one
that has to go alongside never say light
your ID say lately well it depends on
what sport depends on what sport okay in
basketball
thank you well well ince baseball
lefties are crafty
crafty lefty I mean crafty Randy jump
that's one of the many reasons why Randy
Johnson was such an outlier
there was nothing crafty about him every
other lefty every other lefty is crafty
all of them naina tom glavine I'll think
it's the Glavine crab baby right we can
keep going on
crafty I ever even saw lefty Grove I
know he's clever he's crafty that's what
I'm saying I and you take care of
yourself have a great weekend all right
man have a great weekend off thank you
thanks for calling I'm gonna start Game
of Thrones right now yeah we'll see you
by the NBA Finals for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app